in this video I want to talk about
eukaryotic transcription specifically
the general scheme of how it goes
specifically involving enhancers so what
is an enhancer an enhancer is a DNA
sequence far from the promoter that
binds activators to increase the rate of
transcription does that make sense
enhancers increase the rate of
transcription that makes sense now what
is a response element this is another
important term that we need to
understand a response element is a
specific enhancer that responds hence
the name to a particular signal and
there are a few examples and we're going
to actually talk about a specific one
cyclic JMP
we're going to talk about this in a
later video but another thing is steroid
hormones steroid hormones for example
something like testosterone individuals
who want to build muscle
well sometimes take a testosterone as a
steroid hormone and testosterone what it
does is it acts via and enhancers a
specific response element to increase
transcription so an increase in
transcription more mRNA or mRNA means
more protein more protein means more
muscle mass so that's a little fun fact
there for you there are also these
things called activators which are
basically specific transcription factors
so an activator is a protein that binds
a DNA sequence to alter expression of
that gene
now steroid hormone receptors will be
the things that actually bind these
steroid hormones something that we'll
talk about as a specific activator is
CREB we'll discuss that more later a co
activator or a mediator is a protein
that helps form the initiation complex
so we talked about that briefly when we
talked about he fat back in the day
so a take-home point here to keep in
mind is that an enhancer or response
element those are actual sequences on
the DNA whereas these things here are
these activators and co-activators these
are actual proteins so now that we've
got that sort of detail those that
detail out of the way let's actually
apply that knowledge so let's think
about this general scheme here that I've
drawn out so if we imagine a DNA strand
like this and it has a Tata box and a
start site which make up the promoter
region and we have an enhancer that's
pretty far away how would this enhancer
enhance or increase the rate of
transcription
so as we recall from before we first had
to have transcription factor 2d bind the
tata box once transcription factor 2d
binds the tata box it recruits RNA
polymerase 2 and of course the
transcription factors he fab so I'm
going to put here RNA polymerase 2 basal
complex usually the basal complexes also
includes transcription factor 2 D but
I'm just going to put this here to imply
that the other transcription factors are
also coming over here to the promoter
now the third thing that happens is a
specific transcription factor
so put that TF transcription factor will
go ahead and bind the enhancer so now
what's going on here overall we're
having proteins come over to DNA and
interact with them so that is a protein
DNA interaction this here this
transcription factor specific
transcription factor is binding this
enhancer this is a protein interacting
with a particular DNA sequence same
thing over here with this transcription
factor to D binding the Tata box and RNA
polymerase 2 and it's basal complex
another thing that I want to point out
just to mention briefly is that
transcription factor 2d and all those
other transcription factors that come
along with this complex are all basal
transcription factors so anytime
RNA polymerase 2 is coming in those
transcription factors transferred rented
Rudy and he fab will always become in
HVF a and B now further once once this
happens what we're going to get is the
DNA will actually loop around so as to
have the specific transcription factor
that has bound the enhancer it's now
going to interact with the transcription
factor 2d and the RNA polymerase complex
limb raised 2 specifically so now this
in this the reason it looped around so
this protein that is interacting with
this enhancer and these proteins
interacting with the Tata box in the
start site the whole promoter here now
these proteins are actually interacting
here so this is now a protein protein
interaction so these protein protein
interactions what they do is they help
increase the stability of the RNA
polymerase loops the RNA polymerase
initiation complex and that allows for
an increased rate of transcription so
now once this all happens this RNA
polymerase will go ahead and transcribe
and then enhance fashion and that's
pretty much it
hope that video was helpful one more
thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at MOOC University at
gmail.com see the description below for
more details thank you for watching